FOUND OUT HIS CHILDREN WERE
KILLED BY RUSSIAN FIRE.
HE WANTS THE WORLD TO KNOW.
>> I'M SO DEEPLY SORRY FOR YOUR
UNBEARABLE LOSS.
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO SEE
TATIANNA AND YOUR CHILDREN?
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO BURY THEM?
>> Translator: YES, I'VE MANAGED
TO BURY EVERYONE.
I WAS DRIVING FOR THREE DAYS AND
I BROKE IN THERE AND MANAGED TO
BURY EVERYONE.
I EVEN MANAGED TO TAKE AWAY A
PET DOG FROM THERE.
>> SERGEI, I KNOW YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK TO TATIANA THE
NIGHT BEFORE.
IT WAS SO BRAVE OF HER TO TRY TO
LEAVE.
SHE HAD WAITED BECAUSE SHE WAS
CARING FOR HER OWN MOTHER.
WHAT DO YOU REMEMBER FROM THAT
CONVERSATION, YOUR LAST
CONVERSATION WITH HER?
>> Translator: LAST CONVERSATION
BEFORE HER DEATH, THAT WAS THE
DAY WHEN ALREADY THERE WAS NO
WATER, ELECTRICITY, GAS AND WE
DISCUSSED -- I SPOKE TO HER AT
10 P.M. EVEN THOUGH AT THAT
POINT THERE WERE NOTHING EITHER.
I MANAGED TO GET THROUGH AND WE
HAD A DISCUSSION ABOUT POSSIBLE
EVACUATION.
AT THE LAST MOMENT, THE CONVOY
SHE WAS PLANNING TO TRAVEL WITH
WAS SHELLED AND FIRED AT AND
THEN SHE CAME ON FOOT TO THE
BRIDGE TRYING TO MAKE AN ESCAPE
ON FOOT.
>> SERGEI, I HAVE SEEN THE
PICTURES OF HER GOING TO WORK,
YOU KNOW, SMILING, YOU KNOW, IN
WHAT HER LIFE AND YOUR LIFE WAS
LIKE A MONTH AGO.
CAN YOU TELL ME ABOUT HER?
I KNOW THAT YOU'VE BEEN TOGETHER
FOR DECADES, YOU KNOW, WHAT WE
WOULD CALL HIGH SCHOOL SWEET
HEARTS.
CAN YOU JUST TELL US ABOUT HER
SO WE KNOW SORT OF THE WOMAN
BEHIND THAT SMILE?
>> Translator: YES.
WE HAVE BEEN MARRIED FOR 23
YEARS AND IN 2012 WE EVEN HAD A
SECOND MARRIAGE, SECOND WEDDING
BECAUSE WE WANTED -- AT THE
CHURCH.
WE WANTED TO MAKE OUR MARRIAGE
LAWFUL IN THE SKIES ABOVE US.
SHE WAS A VERY CHEERFUL PERSON.
SHE WAS THE FINANCIAL DIRECTOR
OF A LARGE AMERICAN COMPANY.
WE SPENT LOTS OF TIME TOGETHER
AS FAMILY.
WE LAUGHED, BICYCLES.
IN WINTER WE WENT SKIING.
SHE LOVED VERY MUCH PLANTING
FLOWERS, COUNTRYSIDE COTTAGE.
BASICALLY WE LOVED OUR WEEKENDS
TO BE VERY, VERY ACTIVE.
>> SERGEI, AS A PARENT, ANY
PERSON AROUND THE WORLD CAN'T
IMAGINE YOUR UNBEARABLE LOSS,
ABOVE ALL LOSING YOUR
CHILDREN -- CAN YOU TELL ME
ABOUT SNEM THEM?
>> Translator: I CALL THIS THE
WORLD LINE BECAUSE WE USED TO BE
IN OUR FAMILY, WE USED TO USE
GOOGLE GEO LOCATION.
WE USED TO SEE EACH OTHER WITH
MY WIFE ON GOOGLE MAPS, AND THAT
MORNING I NOTICED THAT THERE WAS
UNUSUAL GEO LOCATION BETWEEN
KYIV AND THEIR PING AND THEN 20
MINUTES LATER HER PHONE MOVED TO
ANOTHER LOCATION, TO A HOSPITAL
IN KYIV AND I SUSPECTED
SOMETHING WAS WRONG.
AND I ASKED FRIENDS TO COME TO
THE HOSPITAL AND FIND OUT
WHETHER THERE WERE ANY BAD NEWS,
AND THEN TWITTER, THERE WAS NEWS
ON TWITTER, THERE WAS MORTAR
SHELLING AND THAT FAMILY DIED,
TWO CHILDREN, THEIR MOTHER AND
THEIR FATHER.
AND THEN I SAW A PHOTO ON
TWITTER AND I RECOGNIZED MY
CHILDREN.
I RECOGNIZED THEIR THINGS AND
THEIR CLOTHES.
AND I CALLED MY FRIENDS TO SAY
THE CHILDREN ARE DEAD.
THEIR BODIES ARE LYING ON
PAVEMENT AND I ASKED THEM,
PLEASE COULD YOU HELP ME TO FIND
MY WIFE.
>> SERGEI, IF ANYONE WATCHING
COULD LEARN SOMETHING ABOUT --
ABOUT ELYSA AND NIKITA, WHO THEY
WERE, WHAT WOULD YOU WANT THE
WORLD TO KNOW ABOUT THEM?
>> Translator: THEY WERE NORMAL,
CHEERFUL CHILDREN.
MY SON WAS -- WAS OLDER.
HE WAS 18 AND HE WAS IN SECOND
YEAR OF UNIVERSITY.
HE STARTED -- WANTS TO BECOME AN
I.T. PROFESSIONAL.
STARTED PROGRAMMING AND MY
DAUGHTER -- AND MY DAUGHTER WAS
9 YEARS OLD, AND WHAT SHE LIKED,
DANCING, PAINTING.
SHE STUDIED ENGLISH.
THEY WERE NORMAL, CHEERFUL
CHILDREN.
AND WE HAVE HERE WHERE I AM NOW
FOUR FAMILIES.
ALL OF US RESETTLED FROM THE
DONBAS AREA, AND THIS HOUSE
WHERE I AM NOW IS WHERE MY WIFE
HAD TO BE EVACUATED.
I HA